this short tutorial is about the
confidence interval now we will discuss
step by step what a confidence interval
is and what it is used for let's get
started
what is the confidence interval
in statistics parameters of the
population are often estimated based on
a sample therefore on the one hand you
have the population but since in most
cases you cannot survey the entire
population
or you don't have data about the entire
population you draw a sample now you
want to use this sample to estimate a
parameter of the population parameters
that can be estimated are for example
the mean or the variance let's look at
an example you want to know the hate of
all professional basketball players in
the us in order to figure this out you
draw a sample the mean of the sample is
most likely different from the one of
the population
let's assume that we draw not just one
but several samples which of course you
don't actually do in practice so then
each sample is likely to show a
different mean so in the first sample we
have one mean in the second sample we
most likely have another mean and again
in another sample we have another mean
of course it's also possible that purely
by chance two or more samples have means
which are exactly the same but this is
very unlikely
now it is very useful to know a range in
which the true value will lie with a
certain probability so here we have the
means of our sample but actually we want
to know where the mean of the population
is therefore we want to find out in
which range the true mean value is most
likely to be found this range is called
the confidence interval thus the
confidence interval gives us a range in
which the true mean is likely to be
found with a certain probability
but what is a high probability for the
calculation of the confidence interval
the probability with which a parameter
should lie in the interval must of
course be defined beforehand
as a probability the confidence level of
95 percent or 99
is used very often if a confidence
interval of 95 percent is given
one can be 95
sure that the true parameter value is
located within this interval
let's take a look at the confidence
interval for the mean value of normally
distributed data if your data are
normally distributed
the formula for the confidence interval
for the mean results with x bar plus or
minus set times s
divided by the root of n
here x bar is the mean
set is the set value for the respective
confidence interval n is the sample size
and s is the standard deviation plus
minus results from the fact that we have
once the upper limit with plus and runs
the lower limit with minus how can we
visualize this if we look at the curve
of the normal distribution we can draw
the lower limit and the upper limit the
lower bound is given by x dash minus set
times s
divided by the root of n where we take
the minus for the lower bound and we
have the upper limit with x dash plus
set times s
divided by the root of n
where we use here for the upper limit
the plus the range between the lower and
the upper limits then is the confidence
interval if a confidence level of 95
percent is selected
95 of all values lie within this range
so the next question is where do we get
the set value the set value for the
respective confidence interval
can be read from a table in which the
set values for the respective confidence
level are plotted for the confidence
level of 95 for example the set value is
1.96
this results in the equation x dashed
plus minus
1.96 times the standard deviation
divided by the root of n
the confidence interval can of course be
calculated for many statistical
parameters not only for the mean value
to sum up the confidence interval
indicates in which range the parameter
lies with a certain probability for
example a probability of 95 percent i
hope you enjoyed the video you can find
many more tutorials on datadept.net so
just have a look just google datatab or
use the link in the video description
below bye